[Música]
[Aplausos]
será que é possível a gente estabelecer
relações humanas sem a intermediação do
dinheiro bem até alguns anos atrás eu
levei minha vida como conforme manual da
vida tradicional fc engenharia uma
faculdade renomada depois conseguiu
emprego em uma multinacional ficar
alguns anos até que eu deixei emprego de
lado para montar um negócio
empreendedorismo é mas em 2007 eu tive
um diagnóstico de um câncer bem
agressivo
isso deu uma reviravolta assim na minha
vida é a proximidade com a morte fez com
que eu mudasse um pouquinho uma visão de
longo prazo essa questão de trabalhar
muito
guardar dinheiro é juntar dinheiro
prosperar e pensar muito no futuro né eu
mudei um pouco isso passei a valorizar
mais o momento presente é porque naquela
época não sabia se ia viver muito mais
do que alguns meses mas deu tudo certo
o tratamento tudo bem então passei a
valorizar muito o momento presente então
passou um tempo eu me desfiz da empresa
decidi me dedicar o yoga fiquei dando
aula de ioga há alguns anos até que em
um determinado momento uma nova decisão
nem eu eu algo que sempre fez sentido
para mim foi viajar eu queria muito
viajar
então eu vou fazer o que eu quero fazer
agora mesmo deixei o trabalho deixou de
lado e cai na estrada de que forma é eu
decidi viajar mesmo fazer a viagem longo
prazo mesmo sem ter dinheiro pra isso e
eu entrei eu me locomovo via pegando
carona na beira da estrada algo que hoje
em dia não é tão comum mas é possível
fazer eu ia do dormia na casa de pessoas
que é conhecido pelo caminho na minha
intenção era um primeiro momento
conhecer o nordeste depois do norte
alguns países aqui a vizinhos ao brasil
e não tinha nenhum contato então eu fui
conhecendo gente pela internet ou
pessoalmente
conseguir um lugar para dormir e comida
que é uma pergunta que sempre fazem não
é como é que se consegue começo não
passava fome tem diversas formas e
conseguia comida de diversas formas é
mais fácil do que parece né
em um desses locais que visitei foi
barra grande eleitoral da bahia local
muito bonito uma praia bem bacana e eu
decidi ir pra lá de última hora não
tinha nenhum contato prévio não conhecer
ninguém é um vilarejo pequeno e eu fui
com a cara ea coragem é e ao chegar lá a
primeira o primeiro desafio é conseguir
um local para dormir
então há como não tinha nenhum conhecido
lá nenhum contato eu fui batendo de
porta em porta
principalmente em hostels albergues e
campings oferecendo trabalho em troca de
hospedagem seriam poucos dias né
e naturalmente as primeiras sei lá 1015
portas que bate disseram não precisamos
não queremos né
até que já nos conhecendo assim no final
do dia eu encontrei vete do camping da
eset inclusive fica na nossa localização
tempo do sol bem bonita na frente assim
e eu cheguei prevê difícil a proposta
contém rapidamente uma história e ela
fosse ok eu aceito você e eu ainda
estava no começo da viagem com essa
mentalidade um pouco formal é de
trabalho eu já queria negociar com ela o
que eu ia fazer mas o que eu vou fazer
com essas atividades quanto tempo de
trabalho ela fosse na relaxa é bom essa
barraca dorme descansa tomam banho
amanhã a gente conversa e foi esse o
clima né de de ajuda basicamente todo
dia de manhã que dava e falar com ela
ali passava alguma tarefa de limpeza
dinheiro ele para o banheiro de limpar a
cozinha e fazer algum serviço geral que
durava de uma duas horas pra mim era uma
troca justa porque fazia rapidinho de
manhã eo resto do dia livre para
aproveitar porque estava ali pra curtir
e não para ficar o dia inteiro
trabalhando né
e tinha um local seguro para deixar as
minhas coisas é importante também
e tendo local para dormir com o próximo
passo conseguir comida e eu estava
disposto
para testar diferentes abordagens então
a primeira abordagem que eu queria fazer
era como ele chu choca um pouco né como
lixo
eu fui em alguns mercados é pra pedir
frutas e legumes é que não ia ser mais
vendidos sabe que aquela fruta que está
amassada é um legume que já está com uma
uma pontinha já aquele que é tão bonita
pra vender mais mas que ainda pode ser
aproveitado e eu conseguir nos mercados
que eu fui um deles foi bem interessante
porque eu não só conseguiu os legumes né
uma pessoa que me atendeu ela fez
questão de na cozinha do do local cortar
as partes feias embalar no plástico
filme entregar assim é muito cuidadoso e
fiquei impressionado foi pouco
interessante não está pedindo o lixo
está ganhando uma coisa tão tão bonita
né
e a outra estratégia era que eu queria
muito também em uma padaria de pão velho
né ai foi a primeira padaria e levei um
chá de cadeira então o proprietário ele
não falava não mas ele não me atendia né
normal quando você está numa situação
dessa é tentar preparado para situações
é pra não ficar aqui também o dia
inteiro por causa de de dispensa do pão
velho né
aí fui para a próxima pagaria e foi
direto falar com o gerente já expliquei
minha situação e ele fosse você vai
comer pão velho
senta aí vou mandar fazer dois na chapa
com manteiga e café pra você e também um
belo café da manhã e o chapeiro desse
local ele ficou 16 sintonizou a minha
história e ele ficou conversando também
porque quando você está com tempo livre
você conversa com as pessoas é bacana
estabelece as relações né
e ele permitiu cinco reais e me deu isso
era 2014 mas não foi simbólico é um
shaper me deu cinco reais
naquela época dá pra comparar uma coisa
com cinco reais e aí eu falei mas com 50
também não faço muita coisa né então não
vai salvar
vai meu ver tanta coisa para mim aí eu
virei pro gerente foi se conhecem vete
do camping a conheço então estou ficando
lá ela foi muito legal comigo que ela
vem aqui comprar vem
a compra que aquele café ali aquela
marca deu para comprar café com esse
dinheiro e isso sobrou um troco com um
chocolatinho alguma coisa assim e eu fui
dei prefetti de presente
foi uma coisa simbólica também mas assim
eu tenho vontade de fazer isso pela
forma como ela se abriu para mim assim
né de receber sem perguntar sem querer
saber quem era simplesmente porque
estava precisando né ela também estava
precisando de uma de uma força né
bem é outra coisa interessante que
parece que às vezes conspira quando você
está aberto o camping tinha mangueiras
várias mangueiras e vários roqueiros no
próprio campo inclusive avião redes
protegendo as barracas porque elas
caíram e poderão quebrar uma barraca né
então não precisava nem colheu tinha
manga e coco seco e coco verde todo dia
no chão incrível se então uma parte da
manutenção que inclusive a manga da
bahia é fantástica e eu tirei dele uma
partida das cadeiras que eu precisava
tirei da tencent do coco seco é bem
calórico bem
um belo dia é junto com o pessoal do do
canto em outras pessoas que foram
aparecendo a gente decide fazer uma
longa caminhada para conhecer umas
piscinas naturais de cada um e levar
comida né na sua comida era passar o dia
inteiro para voltar à noite né eu levei
acho que manga mangue coco né
e aí nesse grupo tinha um cara que tava
cinco anos um brasileiro uma da bahia né
é assim quando ele estava tendo uma vida
nômade e ele começou a se posicionar no
grupo como se fosse um líder um guru
espiritual não sei uma coisa assim eu
achei interessante observar e aprender
com esse cara aí para um determinado
momento tinha lá é coco verde ele foi
explicar para vocês como pega um coco
verde para tirar mais fácil assim como
abrir um coco verde com uma faca simples
de cozinha ele nos ensinou a pegada foi
bacana
num outro momento ele ea gente chegou
nos coqueiros mais altos que o cocô cayo
coco seco de onde vem o coco seco
aprendia e ensinava coco seco é esse
corpo está no chão e pra escolher em que
chacoalhar e linense não escolheu
crescer
legal como abrir como tirar a casca
grossa como abrir é um pouco mais
difícil de abrir né pegar a água e poder
comer a polpa né
e ele me ensinou uma coisa bem
interessante que nunca mais tive
experiência na vida em relações a maçã
do coco provavelmente poucos aqui deve
ter ouvido falar quando o coco seco está
no chão na areia e ele começa a brotar
para virar um novo coqueiro forma-se uma
bolinha parece uma maçã branca deliciosa
mas que infelizmente pra você poder
comer você tem que matar aquele coqueiro
então eu vou confessar uma tem um
coqueiro na vida o seu mundo uma vez na
vida não pretendo fazer mais e foi muito
bacana mas o que mais foi legal desse
cara a experiência dele nessa dele se um
líder espiritual né
foi na hora de comer então era só chegar
e comer a gente sentou alguém estender
um pano e todo mundo colocou o que tinha
no pano até aí ok piquenique nada de
nada demais mas ele queria estimular o
compartilhar então elipse vou explicar
de uma forma mais simples de uma maçã
não é só você pegar uma secretaria fica
comendo você dá uma mordida na maçã
passar outro lado apesar dessa medida e
assim a gente vai revezando todas as
comidas e achei muito bacana porque
aquilo foi muito simbólico é um pouco
estranho naquele momento mas foi
simbólica e eu fomos uma das ruas que
levei pra mim assim sempre que tiver
comida principalmente viajando
nessa condição minha meio desprovida né
eu vou sempre dividiu que eu tenho
principalmente as coisas gostosas porque
acho que dividindo vem mais né então foi
uma coisa que eu aprendi bastante ali e
uma outra forma que eu conseguir comida
em outras eu vou resumir pelo tempo da
palestra né que foi bem simbólica também
o pessoal do camping que naturalmente
fiquei amigos estavam acampados né eles
começaram a me oferecer comida deles
porque é uma coisa que eu tenho também
de não ficar pedindo mesmo quando não
tenho nada não peço eu fico na minha
pessoa quiser oferecer ou aceitar mas se
não eu tenho os meus meios para
conseguir né
eles começaram a oferecer comida e eu
aceitava né ea justificativa deve ser
bem interessante não você está limpando
a nossa sujeira gente subir você limpa
em sua cozinha você limpa então nada
mais justo que você comer a nossa comida
né
e outra coisa que aconteceu nesse campo
é bem interessante que a ivete é
contratado um rapaz ela estava sozinho
né
eu estava bem cansada ela já é avó então
estava com aquela correria de camping de
final de ano revelou na bahia verão e
sozinha super cansada eu contrato um
rapaz para limpar o camping e era 50
reais na época a limpeza eo rapaz não
vinha e vinha de um pouco embora não
terminava fazer uma limpeza geral no
campo ela chegou já era o link pra mim
né eu fizesse essa limpeza quer um pouco
mais pesada mas em duas horas eu
terminei o campeonato estava 15 reais
então a limpeza que eu fiz de 50 reais
seria mais ou menos três noites no
camping e teoricamente poderia ficar
três noites à toa
mas esse tipo de conta e eu não faço eu
não fiz porque a nossa troca ela não era
matemática que eu não queria essa
relação comercial eu queria uma relação
spam tânia eu ajudei ela me ajudou e e
eu fico muito mais satisfeito do que o
rapaz estava pagando então pra ver como
que às vezes há uma troca sem dinheiro
ela pode ser feita de uma forma mais
assim humana mais próxima né
sem fazer continhas né ea nossa relação
foi tão legal que eu acabei ganhando nem
só de presente dela é interessante é um
lençol eu precisava de uma só ela tinha
ela e ela me deu foi muito bem marcante
né não
não consigo acho que nunca mais vou
esquecer da ivete né
e eu fiquei então dois anos
estabelecendo relações desse tipo com
diversas pessoas relações que não eram
intermediados pelo dinheiro
o que acontece quando você não tem o
dinheiro intermediando não existe nas
relações é desse tipo o que eu chamo de
interesse interesseiro
então fiquei dois anos praticamente sem
relacionar com pessoas é que tivesse
algum interesse interesseiro sobre mim
eu sobre elas né
é lógico que todas as relações trabalha
baseado em algum tipo de interesse é
natural normal o que eu chamo de
interesse e interesseiro que o dinheiro
proporciona é quando você quando uma
pessoa se aproxima de outro estabelece
uma amizade uma relação
buscando obter algum tipo de vantagem é
uma indicação de clientes ou um cargo
público ou emprego ou até algum status
social um empréstimo com alguma coisa
assim e eu sei que eventualmente nós
vamos ter essas relações mas eu estou
procurando cada vez mais é diminuir se
essa quantidade delas é da minha vida
quero relações que sejam pautadas por
outra por outra lógica né
e essa experiência de de ficar dois anos
vivendo dessa forma ela me mostrou que
quando você não tem a intermediação do
dinheiro a gente consegue ter uma
relação mais franca mais aberta mais
honesta transparente né porque não há
interesses que vão além da própria
convivência é o que eu como nome de
poder oferecer para as diversas pessoas
que me ajudaram as diversas pessoas que
deram carona que me hospedar ão que me
deram comida ou algum outro tipo de
apoio que eu poderia oferecer
basicamente o meu tempo a minha atenção
em pouco das minhas histórias e talvez
uma ajuda pra sair algum serviço nada
mais do que isso então essas pessoas se
aproximaram de mim espontaneamente
porque elas queriam e os sentinelas essa
esse desejo de ajudar né então eu
consegui enxergar através dessas
relações não pautada pelo dinheiro é
algo que o todo ser humano tende muito
precioso dentro de si que a generosidade
de todos nós temos né
eu acredito muito hoje em que se nós
podemos nos doar aos outros é como essas
pessoas que olham para mim como eu me
doei para ela de certa forma também fez
puder fazer algo pelos outros
eu tenho certeza que isso vai retornar o
universo nos traz né
e quando fala fazer algo pelos outros
não é necessariamente a caridade
religiosa que é importante também que
muita gente se dedica e é bacana mas eu
digo é fazer alguém no seu dia a dia com
as suas habilidades com seu tempo né com
o que você aprendeu com a sua atenção
pelos outros sem esperar nada em troca
se a gente conseguir que uma parte do
nosso tempo seja dedicado a isso eu
tenho certeza que isso vai retornar
inclusive materialmente né eu tenho
plena convicção de que matou ao menos
uma parte
das nossas necessidades materiais podem
ser supridas inclusive através desse
tipo de relação que não envolva um
contrato um dinheiro uma expectativa de
retorno né
então voltando à pergunta original na
inicial da palestra será que é possível
estabelecer relações humanas sem
intermediação do dinheiro eu acredito
que não só é possível como é muito
gratificante eu quero levar esse tipo de
relação
pelo resto da minha vida muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]